j'ai une dernière question mais Eric
sooti a annoncé qu'il ne se rendrait pas
aux rencontres de saint-enis vendredi
notamment suite à l'absence du chef de
l'État dimanche à la marche vous vous
soutenez cette décision du président de
votre parti écoutez nous on sort de la
loi sur
l'immigration où on a fait voter un
texte qui à 98 % est-ce que monsieur
sooti a déposé à l'Assemblée nationale
en en même temps on va aller vers ce
débat à l'Assemblée nationale au moment
où on cherche justement à imposer une
ligne plus ferme sur ces sujets là je
pense qu'il vaut mieux continuer à être
présent au discussions avec le président
de la République quitte à lui dire ceci
n'empêche pas cela toutes les
divergences et les différences qu'on a
avec lui c'est donc une erreur de r je
ne dis pas ça moi à sa place j'aurais
pas fait pareil très bien merci Mar de
cette
réaction